[Música]
economía en directo américa ya está
conmigo en el estudio daniel hablando
con daniela bienvenida feliz jueves ya
último programa porque se va a descansar
hasta el próximo martes daniela qué rico
pero vamos a empezar entonces hablando
de una buena noticia para los
trabajadores en méxico hola raúl muy
buenos ya lo estaré pensando mucho desde
mi disfrute por mí ese concierto de
carlos y ahora sí pues miremos las
buenas noticias en mexico económicamente
hablando la mala es que pues tienen una
inflación acumulada del 7.0 5% anual en
la primera quincena de noviembre y esta
su tasa más alta en 20 años la buena
noticia la dio el presidente andrés
manuel lópez obrador y es que la
comisión nacional de los salarios
mínimos acordó un aumento global del
ingreso escuchen otro
pero entre el sector obrero
el patronal y el gobierno por consenso o
aumento del salario mínimo del 22% para
el año próximo que durante nuestra
gestión
el incremento al salario mínimo ha sido
del 65 por ciento en términos reales
ahora qué significa esto raúl pues que
el salario mínimo a nivel nacional será
de
172,87 pesos mexicanos por día un poco
más de 8 dólares y en la zona especial
de la frontera norte subirá de 10 a 12
dólares o más o menos 262 pesos
mexicanos y este anuncio lo hizo
precisamente ayer cuando se cumplió
exactamente tres años desde que llegó al
poder amlo danny pero ahora le pregunto
hablando en materia digamos real para un
ciudadano que puede comprar con este
dinero bueno si me lo preguntan me caso
de turista ción mes en mexico con eso se
puede comprar una buena cena en tulum lo
que es muy costoso ok pero si es vamos a
lo que dice el gobierno ellos dicen que
con este aumento el salario mínimo va a
cubrir el 74 por ciento de la línea de
bienestar familiar o sea las familiar
mientras que en la frontera norte
incluso les sobraría dinero eso dice el
gobierno bueno vamos a ver entonces
cuánto alcanzan los bolsillos de los
mexicanos que viven día a día en ese
país y que tienen que sobrevivir y
comprar alimentos todos los días danny
precios de los alimentos hablando de
alimentos están en máximos en 10 años
claro pues en noviembre subieron por
cuarto mes consecutivo
impulsados principalmente por la demanda
de trigo y de lácteos esto lo dice la
organización de naciones unidas para la
agricultura y la alimentación la fao que
elabora un índice mensual y analiza los
alimentos más comercializados a nivel
mundial lo que ha detectado es que los
precios agrícolas se han incrementado
abruptamente porque hay mucha demanda de
alimentos y las cosechas no son
suficientes cuáles son los que más suben
daniela bueno
póngale cuidado esta lista raúl si se
comparan los precios en general con
noviembre del año pasado subieron 27 3%
pero el alza más grande está en el
azúcar que hoy vale 40 por ciento más
que hace un año sólo los precios del
trigo están en su nivel más alto desde
mayo de 2011 también lo sé en general
subieron 23% los lácteos casi un 20% con
la mantequilla y la leche en polvo
subiendo más que los otros y lo que
menos sube es una buena noticia para
usted al no es una mala noticia para
usted es la carne porque si se compara
con el mes anterior muestra su cuarta
caída mensual pero como usted no come
carne pues no va a ahorrar bueno pero
iguales
es una buena noticia porque pues la
gente puede consumir dejar de consumir
más animalitos danic favelas de brasil
ya tienen su propia bolsa valor es una
muy buena noticia cómo funciona esta
bolsa claro y de ti eso favelas de
brasil dijeron basta a la marginación
económica que llevan por décadas a la
entrada de paraisópolis que es la
segunda para la vela para la vela la
segunda favela más grande de sao paulo
no hay estatuas de toros dorados como en
wall street y si hay decenas de casas de
ladrillo desnudo y hasta una campaña de
lata que es el símbolo de la recién
inaugurada bolsa de valores de las
favelas lo que hicieron fue aliarse con
david hub que es una plataforma de
financiación popular con sede en silicon
valley en california ellos recibieron
todos los permisos de la comisión de
valores inmobiliarios de brasil para
regular la participación de estas
empresas listadas escuchemos
la idea de crear la bolsa de valores de
las favelas surgió para crear un puente
entre las startups y los inversores que
quieren actuar en las favelas de brasil
paga las obras yo el estoicismo es para
mí un estímulo para la población de la
favela que está sufriendo con dos crisis
la sanitaria y la económica que trae
hambre y desempleo y ya tienen hasta una
primera compañía listada raúl se llama
favela brasil express cuyo dueño tiene
apenas 21 años y nació de una necesidad
los problemas que había para entregar
encomiendas compradas en internet él lo
está siendo en favela tenemos que
comprar el mañana que es el 'día sin
iva' aquí en colombia todos los regale
sabía que no falta nada ni indicadores
bueno pues en asia las bolsas operaron
mixtas con los ojos puestos en el avance
de la variante omicron todo eso después
de que a webs twitter le fuera bastante
mal en la sesión anterior las bolsas de
europa operan con pérdidas también por
los riesgos que comienzan a ver los
inversionistas con la variante para
finalizar que nos trae como cifra el día
en ese primer bloque económico
bueno desafortunada también porque es un
6,24 la inflación en perú acumulada
hasta noviembre muy por encima del rango
meta del banco central que es de entre
el 1 y el 3% los combustibles para el
hogar son lo que más sube danny gracias
por toda esa información nos vemos más
adelante con más economía vamos a ver
nuestro reportaje